so what is the difference between
confidence and arrogance a lot of people
seem to be confused because there's a
very very thin line between being
confident and being arrogant arrogance
is probably the most unattractive
off-putting character trait that a
person can have now that you know that
an arrogant person is actually very very
insecure because they have to kind of
advertise how great they are to just
feed their egos and feel better about
themselves but confidence doesn't need
to advertise itself because real
confidence speaks for itself because it
is always combined with humility why
because while arrogance is always busy
trying to prove itself better and more
important than others
confidence knows it is not above anybody
else or below anybody else it knows that
it's fight it's not with other people
who were other things but it is always
seeking to improve itself so it's
important to know that confidence is not
like everybody's gonna like me no no
that is arrogance
confidence on the other hand isn't
knowing that I'll be fine if nobody
likes me because I know who I am and
what I stand for you know that's why I
hate these videos there with these
titles that say how to be cooler than
other guys or cooler than your friend or
better-looking than other people that
mindset is already wrong because the
fight is never with other people but
always with yourself you are your own
worst enemy your focus should always be
on how to improve yourself in mind body
and in spirit and not to be better than
other people it's about improving
yourself to be the best you and to be
better than yesterday now if you
struggle with low self-esteem low
self-confidence let me know in the
comment section down below
and maybe I'll make a video and explain
to you how you can improve your
self-confidence the right way now
let's sum this all up ok what is the
difference between confidence and
arrogance the difference is humility and
if you don't have any and if you're full
of pride then remember this a proud man
is always looking down on other things
and other people and of course as long
as you're looking down you can never see
anything above you
now remember showing that you are humble
while you are confident is not a
weakness but arrogance is a huge
weakness a confident and humble man or
women is not weak at all but arrogance
is a huge weakness and it is disguised
as a strength
because while confidence let you believe
that you can overcome your weaknesses
with arrogance you can't even see your
own weaknesses well everybody else can
now that's very deep so take some time
let it sink in and I'll see you in the
next video
sure